rooster you're on the air
i ran into a gentleman yesterday this
was an officer now being a fellow
officer i thought we had mutual
understanding i drove into a speed trap
and i wasn't even speeding was 45 and a
40. and i told the officer i said this
is obviously a speed trap there's a
curve right there if i was maintaining
that speed i would run into the curve
and obviously i'm not an idiot i'm not
going to do that and i think the dude
was just about ready to just give me a
warning and let me go and i told him i
said this feels real weird out of 20
years of being a department of
correction officer i've never been
pulled over and then he gave me a ticket
for doing 45 and a 40. you mean to tell
me a fellow officer gave you a ticket
yes
i don't know one cop
ever got a speeding ticket from another
cop and i know guys i don't know every
cop first of all and second of all why
is rooster doing so much talking
that's part of the problem dude instead
of doing all that yapping why don't you
go hey officer hey i'm uh i'm sergeant
what are you what's your rank uh i was a
colonel
you say i'm a colonel
yeah colonel sanders
[Laughter]
russia you don't go i'm retired uh
corrections officer i'm a colonel
and when i said that he looked at me and
he goes well i feel sorry for you
wolfie what the [ __ ] is going on here
rooster's a former cop and he got a
ticket from another cop this is new to
me i i know of uh family members that
get pulled over you just say oh my
uncle's on the job and they let you go
you better go talk to your fellow
ex-officers and say what am i doing
wrong because i didn't get the essential
perk it's a horrible thing that some
people get to be above the law but i'm
just pointing out the reality ronnie
doesn't get tickets and he's nobody's
nephew when you go in ronnie's car the
entire dashboard is lined up with these
[ __ ] pba
i made up like this whole plaque
of every pba card that i had
and it would just it would just sit on
the dashboard ronnie got an accident he
almost got beheaded by his plaque
one of those badges flew off and stuck
in his head ronnie had so many cards and
badges you couldn't even see over the
dash it was crazy i mean they would walk
over and they would just look and they
would laugh and they would go
slow down have a nice day
you think i bruised his ego when i
called him on it was a speed trap i
wasn't there but i wish i had tape of it
i'd love to see how you [ __ ] this up
i think in the beginning i sensed this
dude was a prick and i kind of [ __ ]
with him a little bit well you [ __ ] up
now the truth the truth is coming out
now
yeah you shut you you showed him you
showed him